I want to talk to you about pure script
and I'm going to try to convince you
that it's the future of programming
languages and it has the future in it
and it's the future of JavaScript and
you can have the future of JavaScript
today if you want it if I going to make
a claim like that I should probably go
back a bit in time and give it some
context and say how we've got where we
are javascript has a kind of curious
history as a programming language it has
some things that make it utterly amazing
and the big one to me is that it's the
only programming language that your
grandmother can run you can send source
code to your gran and she can run it
without any instructions I'd have a
whole running programming language no
other programming language in the world
can make that claim it's so universal
and the other thing which I think is
amazing about JavaScript and I think a
lot of developers either don't know this
or have forgotten it but we spent most
of the last decade making sure there was
one JavaScript not one per browser even
several different languages for each
browser that that engineering F at that
coordination you try and get Google and
Apple and Microsoft to agree on
something and you'll appreciate how hard
it is we are very lucky to have one
language that can reach everybody we
would never want to lose that but it has
some faults too javascript was
undeniably rushed into production right
it famously had a design phase of two
weeks and it was kind of the design was
make it look like Java and test the
creator's ideas about how inheritance
should work that was basically the
design it was never really designed to
be a scaled programming language on the
scale that we have at the backend right
we were very lucky that we got something
that could do more than pop-ups
there are wort there are lots of lots of
rough edges in JavaScript and they're
not going to be fixed the last release
of the JavaScript spec convinced me of
that they're going to add things but
they're never going to fundamentally
look at the underlying assumptions and
the other thing that's problem with
JavaScript is honestly I don't think the
design would have surprised anybody back
in the eighties or nineties the
inheritance model was novel automatic
memory management was becoming
mainstream other than that it wasn't a
startling language which puts us in this
position right now I think where there's
a lot of stuff about JavaScript who keep
and a lot of stuff we would get rid of
we would definitely keep the fact that
your grandmother can run it your uncle
your aunt your child we would sort out
some of the fundamental bugs in this bed
we would look for something that's still
going to work well when you get over ten
twenty thousand lines of code I think
that's a struggling point in any
JavaScript project and it's still a
struggling point even if you say we're
going to have ten code bases of twenty
thousand lines of code each and god
forbid we would actually look at
computer science research and learn a
couple of lessons from what's happened
since the millenium right we could do
that we could as an industry we could
ignore a few agile thought leaders and
actually learn from academia this might
be a nice thing we can cherry-pick from
the future and unsurprisingly I'm going
to tell you that one way to cherry-pick
from the future is pure script so what
is it it's a programming language but
compiles to JavaScript that instantly
means we can redo all the semantics and
all of the spec without losing any of
the universality it
actually cherry picked some of the best
ideas from computer science in the past
20-30 years and that's really what I
want to tell you about today those big
ideas that make a big difference and
there really is a rich seam of ideas
there's a lot of stuff that was starting
to become fruitful research around the
turn of the millennium but we haven't
really learned from as a mainstream
industry and we should because there's
there's bags of stuff that we can learn
from we can use we can even steal and
put some of it into JavaScript there are
riches there before we get into those
four big ideas I have to I have to grab
the tiger by the tail and say the most
dangerous thing you can say outside of
Emacs versus of in type systems right
I don't like discussions about type
systems because they're never
discussions be holy wars you know people
like politics one side talks and the
other side talks and neither side is
listening some you're gonna despite the
fact that pure script is a statically
typed language I'm going to try and
avoid mentioning starting type static
typing as far as I can I'm not
interested in the holy war I'm
interested in what a language can do for
me and if I do mention types I'm gonna
try and at least say something new
rather than rehash the same old
arguments that's my promise to you I
would do my best so the big ideas for
pure script let's get into it
algebraic data types this is my one
piece of jargon I'm gonna throw at you
it's incredibly important it's
fundamental to me since I discovered
this this has become my dividing line
for what counts is a modern programming
language does it have algebraic data
types you must be this tall to ride this
right what are algebraic data types why
the jargon well they're actually really
really simple and most of the pieces
you've already seen the first thing is
the ability to describe new data by
combining old data together so you might
say that a user has a common
of a string and a date and a boolean
with labels right you could say that
there's an and operation every language
has this if it's C you have struts
JavaScript has this of course is sort of
plain JSON object every language has
some variant of the and operation on
types but if when you start to think
about it as an and your next question
instantly becomes where's that all and
or is an operation unless you choose
between things right so you can say that
a role is a guest or a premium account
base account of staff but it's only one
of those things no one is both a guest
and staff simple most statically typed
languages have this idea probably isn't
enum and if you learnt about it in you
will have seen a textbook that said part
spades clubs diamonds right dynamic
languages tend to have this by default
because you can just make anything
anything which is a blessing and a curse
one thing that's important though that
that dynamic languages miss is the
constraint the or is just between these
things you know it's not hearts diamonds
spades clubs salted licorice it there's
a limited set of possibilities so what
an algebraic data type is is the mixing
and matching freely of ands and ORS to
make new data it's a very simple idea
but most languages don't make that extra
step to say both I can combine anything
together and I can exclude possibilities
now Java lets you do minimal combination
but you can exclude JavaScript lets you
do maximal combination but no exclusions
anything can always be anything else so
here's an example of pure script data
where I've done this right and this is a
very good description of what may be I
know a strike response would be from a
payment provider I can look at that and
and describe all the different responses
I'll get back and know that I'm not
describing anything else
it's a very useful concise way of
talking about gravity about describing
data incidentally almost this is a
solution - you may not see straight away
let me take you through it a solution to
Tony [ __ ] billion dollar problem the
problem of nulls right one of the big
problems in JavaScript which leads to
type of undefined it's not a function
everywhere is that any piece of data
that you think is a string can also be
null or undefined for numbers it's even
worse right it can be and the number you
think it is or now are undefined or not
a number or infinity or minus infinity
and if you're writing code that assumes
it's a number you're writing code that's
wrong you're writing code that relies on
hope you have no way of excluding these
things new script does it starts with
the assumption this that you don't make
everything optional and then makes it
easy to add that optionality back in
later that just the ability to say okay
or is cheap so we won't assume or now
we'll let you yet do it just that
pattern eliminates the null pointer
exception problem and we've known this
for well since I was a teenager that
dates me or it dates ideas we're not
learning this this is a terribly
valuable idea if it were just this it
would be a revolution in software
reliability and we can abstract that out
out that pattern but that's almost an
aside we have a solution to non pointer
exceptions we should be using it so
that's the first big idea algebraic data
types a way of describing our data and
saying what it is and crucially what it
is not and I want to give you a quote I
am rich Hickey who is the designer of
closure a very very good popular
functional dynamic programming language
that those are the exact words but let
permit me to rephrase he said there's no
such thing as a system that doesn't have
assumptions in a description about its
data the only question is whether you've
got a way of writing it down whether
you've got a way of notating it or if
you're just relying on examples all
systems have algebraic data types the
only question is whether they let you
write them but it's not just about data
description it leads under the second
big idea which is consistency in systems
right we can leverage the tale algebraic
datatype to get consistency but for that
we have to ask how do we make software
work at the moment right what do we do
to make our live systems work and I
think we do it like this we start off
with the system we start over the unit
of software and we say there's the
inside of it that I'm working on right
now and then there's the outside world
and in order for this relationship to
work my unit of software is going to
need something from you it's gonna need
some argument and it's gonna provide
something it provides the result the
return value right how do we get that
right I think we get these units right
by doing this we we get the inside right
with tests and hoping it works and we
get its relationship with the outside
world right by writing documentation and
hoping it works right I really think
it's a bit more like this I think we
write a lot of tests to get the inside
right and we have a lot of hope that the
people will use it right and the bit of
documentation but be honest not as much
as we know we ought to but we never do
and I think the situation is actually
worse than this right it's it's more
like this because in a whole system you
have little units of lots of tests and
lots of hope that it fits together and
what we do as an industry is we take
this circle here and we make it larger
and we call that integration testing and
then we realize that integration testing
is slow so we make it smaller again and
then at the end of the Sprint
we make it as big as possible and we
call that QA
but we're still doing the same thing to
make things correct we're not doing it
we're not really addressing the
relationships between units except
trying to say that this is a larger unit
as an aside I think my mother-in-law
would have loved this slide because she
knows nothing about programming she was
a painter but she would have seen
relationships and hope on a slide and
she would have been in the audience very
happy so how do we get these
relationships right unlike human
relationships there are some answers to
this all you need is a really good
linter write a really good linter can
link we love linters in javascript a
really good linter such as ships with
pure script can help you tighten up
these relationships and let me show you
how that's done by asking you what's
wrong with this code
I'm hoping that this is actually too
hard a question I'm hoping almost none
of you can answer that it's unfair I
only showed you the data description for
about 60 seconds but would it be any
more fair if I shown you the data
description for an hour six months ago
no it wouldn't
you would have to track back to find out
what's going wrong here well if you've
actually taken the time to write out
what the data will be you can leverage
that the pure script linter if you will
can look at this and tell you exactly
what's wrong we've missed out two cases
there are two other things that the
payment response can be it can be in it
two different kinds of error which we've
chosen to make distinct what's exciting
about this is anywhere I use this type
payment response the system can check
throughout the system that I've got a
relationship between what I said it was
in one place and how I'm using it in
another anywhere for free all my
relationships with that piece of data
get checked for practically free what's
even more exciting is when I go back and
correct those two errors and the the
linter says and nothing is wrong with
this I know I'm done I'm not relying on
hope to make sure that I've covered all
the cases I have some proof the things
are going to work you know things things
might I still might get the logic wrong
but I'm not going to find that whenever
I try and handle a payment response
things blow up because I just forgot so
you get this thing where you can define
your data once in in a very free easy
descriptive way with an algebraic
datatype and you can get it
it's relationship to all your other
units checked for pretty close to free
this is a great thing for reliability
you also get a kind of documentation if
you look at this error this is this is
the documentation you need where you
need it right these are the missing
cases that you needed to think about at
the exact point you needed to think
about them that's valuable you also and
this leads into the next idea have a
look at this code this is saying there's
some function which I've deliberately
given a useless name it takes a payment
response and it gives you back HTML
you can probably guess what that's going
to do you know it's this is gonna be
somewhere saying your order is confirmed
or there was a problem processing your
credit card right just from that
signature you can get a reasonable
intuition about what this code is if I
show you one more example this is going
to take a user and return an array of
payment responses I would hope a few of
you could guess that maybe this is show
my billing history just from the
description of what it needs and what it
gives you back this is probably going to
be something that deals with getting a
user's list of payments right and this
leads into the next big idea of your
script which is that these type
signatures aren't just at all for
correctness but at all for design and
the history of programming we've had a
lot of attempt at doing languages that
describe the design of a system right
there's plain old documentation and
prose is still very valuable this UML
which is something somebody in an
enterprise used last year to try and
tell you what to do this year and there
are these unit test descriptions that
say describe blah it should blah right
we've got different ways of describing
what the design ought to be but they all
lie all of these design design languages
lie as useful as they would be they get
out of sync with the system we're
writing all design languages lie except
one I have discovered a design language
that actually tells me the truth and I
want to share it with you
so have a look at this code right this
is I think it's from the react tutorials
and I'm deliberately gonna cheat and not
show you this for long enough to
actually figure out what it's doing
let's have a look at the pure script
equivalent this is some code that says
there's a function called calculate
winner it takes an array of maybe a tile
or there may be nothing there and
returns maybe a tile or maybe nothing
there right I can I can get that just
from looking at the signature at the top
you might have an intuition about what
this does if I tell you one more fact
that the tile is either an X or a no
hands up if you can figure out what sort
of thing this is doing yeah reasonable
number yeah good good this is I don't
really call it tic-tac-toe or knots and
crosses over here
but it this is yeah you can look at this
code and say yeah okay this makes sense
what this is doing is taking an array of
tiles X's or OS that may or may not have
been placed and returning either an X or
an O or nothing to calculate the winner
this is a function from the Norse and
grasses but you can see that structure
just in the type signatures so you can
start without looking at the actual code
without looking at this whole code body
you can get a sense of what this is
doing and know that it's telling the
truth because it's consistently checked
with the body of the code but you can
analyze it independently of the body why
is that useful well it starts to become
really useful when you see code like
this let me give you a similar example
the difference here is calculate winner
takes a tile and what is the board an
array of moves and the result it takes a
tile takes either an X or an O as its
first argument I can look at that I've
had quite a bit of experience reading
these type signatures but I can look at
that and say what is it about
calculating the winner in noughts and
crosses that means you need to know the
current player
why do you need to know it's X's turn to
see who if someone's one we don't I can
just look at the type signature this
function I can tell is something wrong
with the design
I just have to look at it and use logic
and see the summer and I don't need to
look at the code body to say something
is wrong about the way this code is
designed it could be simpler let me give
you a more a larger and more horrendous
example of how we can start to use the
type signatures a standalone design
information which we know is correct
against the body so this is an example I
took from the moment J s documentation
there's a function that lets you say
lets you figure out if a date is between
two other dates and it takes as an extra
argument whether you want to have a
granularity of hours minutes years or
whatever and another argument which this
is why I picked in this particular
example I find this absolutely
horrendous the fourth argument is a
mixture of angle bracket a square
brackets and round brackets to say
whether or not it's inclusive of the
start and end value or exclusive yes I
picked a deliberately horrendous API to
make the point that give me the heebie
jeebies if I were to have this code in
pure script I could ask the pure script
system what's that what's the signature
of this code what is the abstract design
of this function and it would say this
is between is a function which takes a
moment and a string and string and a
string which might not be there and a
string which might not be there and
returns a boolean great so horrible
design for a function I can just look at
that and I can tell you what's going to
go wrong when people use this people are
gonna get the strings in the wrong order
people are gonna forget which ones are
optional and worst of all people are
going to forget what the format of those
four different strings is supposed to be
to get it right and you're gonna have to
go to the documentation to figure it out
and you're gonna get it wrong and
sometimes and only know when you go to
run it that it went wrong just looking
at type signature I see problems like
the kid in the film sees dead people
I see bugs
if I if I were to do this in pure script
I would this is how I refined it first I
would get a hold of this horrible string
that says includes excludes and I would
define myself a way of saying I can tag
dates with whether they're supposed to
be inclusive of that range or exclusive
and then I would say hang on that sounds
like a useful tool for integers for
ranges of integers so I might be a bit
more abstract and I would just use this
mechanism that lets me tag any datatype
as being inclusive or exclusive in three
lines of code from that and a little bit
more work I could start to tidy up this
does this type signature to say okay is
between takes a moment and another
moment with the sense of inclusivity and
another moment the sense of inclusivity
and a unit of granularity and return to
boolean that has far a far far smaller
surface area to go wrong you can look at
that and get a much clearer sense of how
to use it and how to get it right and I
can still see one bug in that looking at
it people even get start and end dates
the wrong way around so there's more
work we can do but I'm absolutely
certain that that is a better design
than the previous design it's easier to
see where it's going to go right and how
it'd be hard to get it wrong so type
these type signatures the these design
descriptions which you get almost for
free can start to help you get a get a
handle on where your system is too
complex but it goes a lot further than
that and that's the fourth big idea I
want to give you which is this idea of
complexity tracking automatic complexity
tracking to introduce that idea they TVO
quote from a quarry house well I don't
know but I'd like to meet one day but I
saw I said this on Twitter recently and
that's the exact quote but let me put it
in my own words if you want to make code
testable and sometimes that's a synonym
for reliable you have to start
separating out the stuff that's just
logic with the stuff
it requires an external system to work
correctly it's much easier to write code
which is just a pure transformation and
get it right and much easier to test
than it is to deal with code that needs
a back-end server or a database or the
file system right mo now this is true in
any language you're writing but almost
no languages give you any help to get
this right
except of course what other what are the
language I'll be talking about so let me
give you an example of how this works
spot the difference between these two
functions there is summarize document
which takes a string needs a string and
gives you a string in return presumably
it's going to take the first n
characters or something
there's fetch document which takes a
document ID and gives you back a string
right you might imagine that that going
to the server and then there's rendered
document which takes a string doesn't
give you anything back which is curious
it must be doing something useful but
it's not going to give you a result and
this is as far as most languages will go
but pure script has this way of
analyzing the code you've written and
telling you not just what it needs and
what it provides but giving you an idea
of what kind of work is involved in
getting to that result and so it would
look like this
summarized document I can look at that
type signature and I know it's pure if
when I come to testing I know that this
is going to be easy to test because the
type signature tells me it's just a pure
transformation from string to string to
appreciate that you have to see
something that isn't pure so fetch
document what this is saying is fetch
document is a function which takes a
document ID and at the end will return
you a string but in order to give you
that string it's going to need to have
the side-effect of Ajax write it in
order to fill its contract of document
ID to string that strings going to
involve the network
one more example render document right
this is going to take a string and it's
not going to give you anything back so
did it actually do anything yes
because in order to give you back than
nothing it's going to somehow involve
the Dom now whether you write this in
JavaScript or pure script those
functions are still going to do the same
thing the important point is you can see
it here you can see which code is pure
you can see which code is side effecting
and you can see which side effects are
involved and so you can actually get a
handle on where the complexity is right
if when as I look at these type
signatures I know that summarized
document is going to be easy to test I
know that fetched document is gonna be
that much harder I might want to spin up
a Mach sir a dummy server or I might
want to mock it out and I know that
render document is going to be a
nightmare because in order to properly
test this I actually need to spin up
selenium or something I can look at
these three type signatures and know how
hard my day is going to be which is nice
I might as well accept the reality right
as you go into the office the big point
here is that it's not just about what a
function needs and what it provides but
how much goes into their calculation
that makes a huge difference to
complexity and I like to think of
side-effect is like the complexity
iceberg right traditional function
signatures just tell you what's on top
they don't tell you what's actually
involved in producing that result and so
you have this this hidden mass of this
is much harder than we thought it was
because it involves the differences
between ie and Chrome or Firefox it's
the Mozilla guy in the room
no I don't have to say Firefox and you
can imagine that this has a great effect
on knowing which parts of your code are
going to be easy to test and which
you're going to be harder to test it
also has the effect that if someone
comes in and says there's a bug in this
code when we run it in IE I've got a
pretty good idea which functions are
going to matter and which functions I
can exclude from my debugging search
just by looking at which ones involve
the Dom for instance so it's a great
tool for narrowing down at debugging
time and pure script is one of these
very few languages that has a notion of
tracking complexity contract tracking
which side effects are involved there's
pretty much pure script and elm and
Haskell
and there's a curiosity rust rust is a
language that just as far as I know just
tracks the side effect of consuming
memory which is novel closure script
sorry closure doesn't have compile time
tracking but it is very concerned about
tracking the effect of mutation over
time
but pure script is nice in that you can
track arbitrary effects and be as
granular or granular or general as you
like so in summary the big ideas in pure
script to me the big features are you
can track what data is and what it is
not and you can start to leverage that
as a way of checking relationships
between code and that there globally
correct - for almost free you can track
the growing complexity of a system and
then we can begin to do what curry says
which is separating out the stuff that
isn't so complex computationally with
the stuff that requires other
complications other systems which are
going to make it hard and we can start
shifting the code more to the pure world
and personally one of my favorite ideas
is we can automatically get these type
signatures which give us an idea about
our design we can start improving the
design by looking at our code in the
abstract in a way that we know is true
unlike almost every other abstract
analysis of code going we get a
guarantee about this relationship so we
can do like almost like Brett Victor has
talked about you can really understand
the system when you can look at it in
the concrete and the abstract and jump
between the two easily that's what
that's why pure scripts type signatures
are a design system that really helps in
real code I have a talk about that about
types of design tools if you're
interested in more of that in short all
these tools together let me because I'm
running out of time so let me just say
that all these tools do actually take
you to the future of of large-scale
front-end code reliability
anecdotally I've done a lot of work in
pure script and elm and they both have
similar systems for this they're both
they're more alike than Anna like and
every single one of those systems that
I've written in recent years has needed
a bit of JavaScript
you know maybe five timpz into the code
bases JavaScript and all my bugs or my
runtime exceptions all my problems come
from that five 10% the rest is
rock-solid
I don't worry about I worry about
logical errors but I don't worry about
the reliability of my code anymore in
the front end and I've done consulting
work for companies where managers have
got me in and said after our coders
spend all their time writing tests and
our code still isn't reliable and the
reason is that language isn't up to it
and we know how to make languages that
are up to it and it works we can have
reliable software with a handful of
simple tools made of big ideas that have
been known for a couple of decades we
should do that do it do it join me join
me in the future I would love to delve
more into the code but I'd rather
transmit the big ideas so if you want to
get started go and find yourself the
pure script by example book will
handhold you through the details it's a
very good book it's available online for
free you may want to give the author
fill your money that's a very good idea
I recently tried to give bartosh my
money for his book and then I found out
that he's not being paid for it so I'm
gonna try and buy him some salted
licorice before the end of the
conference I'm sure he loves it and you
might want to take a photo of that and
just run those commands in your browser
and you can have your very own
playground for pure script give it a try
learn the ideas steal them if you want
to and take them to work they work they
really work thank you